but let me tell you I mentioned Gruden
for one specific reason because
yesterday he addressed the future of his
quarterback Derek Carr getting to the
point of his contract would be very easy
for the Raiders to move on yeah and
Bruton was specifically asked yesterday
about this prospect of going forward as
the Las Vegas Raiders with Derek Carr as
the quarterback here's what Gruden had
to say yeah he played he played good I'm
not gonna get into all the next year
scenarios I'm just gonna say that you
know seven and nine is a step forward
you know we took a step forward
you know statistically I think we took a
step forward we got to get a lot of guys
healthy and we got a lot of things to
look at and evaluate before we start
making any assumptions now here's the
thing if Andy Reid gets asked that
question about Patrick Holmes if John
Harbaugh gets asked that question
against about Lamar Jack yes right young
franchise quarterback right they're not
gonna say I'm not gonna get into next
year's scenarios they're gonna say well
are you kidding of course he's our guy
right what are you talking about you're
gonna ask me that question do you watch
football so the mere fact that Jon
Gruden answered the question the way he
did shows that car's status I agree is
in doubt and they're gonna look around
and see what's out there and Chris there
are plenty of guys out there this year I
did a post at PFT the other day to
listing all of my forgot some of my to
go back in that Teddy Bridgewater there
are plenty of guys who are either going
to become free agents or who are going
to likely be available via trade or
they're gonna be released there I'm like
there's over 15 right quarterbacks out
there with recognizable names and I just
think that Jon Gruden is gonna be
looking for somebody else whether it's
Jameis Winston or someone else I think
they're gonna look and see what else is
out there and I think Derek Carr could
very well be gone yeah it's a really
tough one it really is and I don't you
know Derek cars play was good it was
solid there's no doubt about that
I think what's gonna drive Jon Gruden
crazy is you know maybe that lack of
and leadership and fire and things like
that Gruden likes those kind of guys he
likes Rich Gannon he like Jeff Garcia
you know he was you know egging me on as
a young quarterback hey you got a you
know sometimes swear it guys and tell
the office they gonna do better and you
know be that guy he wants that and I
don't know if Derek Carr has that aspect
that Jon Gruden likes let alone
I do think Rudin likes that kind of guy
that can kind of take over a game when
his play doesn't work the right way ooh
he's my get-out-of-jail-free card this
guy cuz he can move extend to play do
all those things that's where I just go
in I don't know if Derek Carr's the guy
but yet is there somebody better out
there to replace him and Derek cards
play was good this year and it's not
like he was surrounded by an ultra high
level talent at the wide receiver
position so yeah he's gonna do his due
diligence I just don't know right now is
sitting here you know December 31st if I
see a guy that I could say that's gonna
be a free agent and go oh he's better
than Derek Carr I could see them taking
taking a shot on him or different than
maybe it just the same as Derek Carr but
with that fire right and I recall
vividly two years ago when it first
started to emerge the Jon Gruden was
under consideration returned to the
Raiders and we were getting those I
somebody contacted me who is very
plugged in and said this isn't gonna
last between Jon Gruden Derek Carr it is
not going to last now I'm surprised this
last of two years and the reason it has
I think Jon Gruden has restrained
himself sure and and he there was so
much talk about could Jon Gruden and
Derek Carr mesh and Gruden was very
careful to make it clear you know I'm
not a raving lunatic and I think he used
words to that effect I understand how
I'm gonna have to deal with this guy and
I think he'd prefer to be the raving
lunatic I think he wants to be the guy
who is full blown hundred-percent Jon
Gruden all the time and does not want to
have to restrain for fear of of a
shattering of fragile ego I hear you and
and and so that's I think two years of
Jon Gruden not being Jon Gruden it's
probably enough for him and he wants to
go back to being Jon Gruden you gotta be
true to who you are I mean I respect
anyone who is true to who they are and
he believes as you've said before if
you're if
if playing in the game is a break from
what you have to deal with during
practice and during meetings that makes
you more prepared for the game I think
he wants to be that guy yeah hurry up
you don't hurry up get out of the huddle
ten nine I mean that was every day of my
life
hurry up make the check and I got out of
the game I was like holy cow thank God
that little 5/7 Napoleon is not behind
me anymore this was a great I was like
this is so fun I don't have to deal with
Mussolini anymore this is great and it
worked it did I felt no pressure in the
game because I didn't have him the
breathing down my neck oh but you still
have to deal with Mussolini you can run
but you can't hide
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports